Angelina Jolie is adjusting to life  without Brad Pitt finding solitude in a  new estate a source tells ET the actress  and her six children moved into a Malibu  rental home on Monday  shortly before news broke of the  couple's divorce filing here's a closer  look at Jolie's beachfront property that  sits close to the Pacific Coast Highway  Matt expects Zahara Shiloh and twins  Viviane and Knox are reportedly staying  with their mother in the 5-bedroom  5-bath home worth nearly 12 million  dollars while the Malibu mansion is  close to a busy street the gated home is  surrounded by tall trees giving her and  the kids privacy apparently the  Maleficent star is renting out the place  month to month for $95,000  [Music]